we're going to speak today i know about
a clip that a scene that you
and egiel have selected from the film um
can you just situate that for us a
little bit just speak to
you know what the film what the scene is
and where in the film it's located
so that viewers can watch it and then
we'll come back and talk about it a bit
it's very short story but one of my
favorite episodes of the film it's about
chickens because we normally believe and
i believe in every expression in any
language there is expression like
stupid like a chicken right so and and
this is kind of
in our mind that they are stupid and you
can see in the film
they're not stupid they're thinking
they have emotions they feel and this is
the moment when they first time
experience
freedom this is the moment their first
time
touching the grass touching the ground
and go
from the jail they used to be all their
life
uh
oh
[Music]
so
oh
[Music]
victor i've noticed you know that
animals have
been a part of all of your films
especially dogs and
one of the most interesting things that
i think you've achieved with this film
gunda is situating animals
and and as protagonists in an ethical
relationship with the viewer
simply by conveying the value animals
have for their own lives and not because
they're in any way like
us and i think this has a really
profound ramification for the
documentary field and for how all
participants
in films are treated actually and also
how in this case the viewers also
reminded of their own animal nature
it's really groundbreaking and i think
this achievement has a lot to do with
how you directed
and also how you and egil decided to
film this and so i wondered if you could
speak to that with our scene ceiling
scene stealing chicken peggy that we've
just seen
um can you can you speak to the clip
that you chose and and the role of the
camera and and how you chose
you know how you guys set up this scene
and
how you chose to film it and also can i
can i first can i just a little bit
it was you said directed and this is
wrong for this film because i did not
direct it
it was opposite i was privileged to
spend
time with those seminars i with all of
them it was
absolutely opposite of
our intention we did not want to direct
it we just wanted to be close if they
allow us
and that's why i invited again he has
this
unique ability to find perfect distance
between camera
and and character i saw i saw it in his
previous film as he did
as director and as steady command and
cameraman
a cinematographer so that's why i when
when i knew i gonna make film about
animals i knew i know i
knew i need someone very delicate
who feel any movement any any
mimic any position of body he feel
can you go closer or you should not can
we go
tiny bit closer or better to go tiny bit
back
and that's why i'm i i invited a girl
and i'm so happy about it that's why so
it's kind of
collective collective job which i am so
happy
again do you want to speak about how you
how you adjusted
your you know steadicam shots
are are the steadicam is very heavy and
and bulky how did you how did you
actually prepare for this and
how did you and victor come together to
decide how you were going to shoot this
i mean from the beginning victor had
this sort of idea that
we need to spend time with these and
care for these
animals like we would have done with uh
with any character in any film
and the the sort of whole idea of the
film
from from victor's point of view as i
understood it was to try to portray
these animals
in the most beautiful and most profound
way that we could do to
to give them the respect that they
deserved and uh
i think like victor also pointed out the
or my mission
or our mission together was to come as
close as we could to them to try to sort
of
experience as a maybe as the viewer a
little bit of
spending time together with with these
animals and it was the same thing with
the chickens
we spent a lot of time with them trying
to get
clothes trying to figure out how we
could
you know basically hang around with them
so the camera almost becomes a character
on its own
spending time with chickens and we hope
that the viewer also will
do the same and you just think that
sorry sorry i will just continue
interesting jocelyn
the hysterical is huge right but aggie
is almost invisible
so you cannot normally come close to
chicken you usually run away
but he's so delicate he's
he's almost like a cat i'm sorry cat is
wrong because
they were afraid i don't know they they
did not consider him as any threat
he he came and so smoothly
so gentle so delicate he came close to
them
and they didn't run they were just
they took him as a part of environment
they just first time experienced this
new environment and steadicam was just
part of it
and this is why it's amazing yeah it's
true i mean most people
in filming this kind of thing you know
they would have used a
lens that would have allowed them a lot
of distance and move in on it with the
lens
and it's very clear throughout this film
that there's an intimacy in the way that
you're moving you
obviously are close closer much closer
to the animals than most people would be
when they're filming animals and
especially chickens are very skittish
as anyone who's been on chicken nose um
and so it's it's really amazing the sort
of
intimacy that you achieve and also it
seems like
i mean it feels like the animals are
coming to you
um as opposed to you coming to them
um so it's it's i mean what were your
lens choices
in filming this and and if you want to
speak
to the scene that we've just seen but
you know to the chickens in general if
you like
i think in general we decided that we
wanted two different approaches one
which was uh observing them from a
distance and
leaving them on their own uh which we
chose for parts of the film but other
parts of the film we wanted to be
as close as possible physically because
it creates a different
feeling of of space and
it would be the same if you filmed any
person in a film you you needed to spend
a lot of time
together with them to gain their trust
and it was the same process with
filming this film and with gundam with
the chickens
with the with the cars that are also in
the film that
it was a long process of gaining trust
and it was a long process of just
hanging out with these
with these animals and having the
privilege to spend time at the farm
uh kind of in itself uh made us
able to maybe come this close
and and so and in terms of the sort of
patience required while you're filming
there's a lot of there's a lot of things
that reveal themselves in the film
you know when you're watching the
chickens in particular um
there's this there are these moments
where you realize
watching that they're experiencing
things
that they've never experienced before
simply by virtue of being released
into the world can you speak to that a
bit because
it's really like my experience was a
kind of awakening
watching watching that and it really
just unfurled very organically
and that seemed to me to take enormous
patience from you all filming because
that could have
that could have taken months and months
right to have something
in a way in a way just like his opposite
in a way it was just one take all of it
it was just one take we did not even we
didn't do anything double we did not
make second take it was just because
those chickens they never experienced
freedom
so just one second before we start this
clip
we saw the first time one of them
trying to touch grass by her feet and
and she was like she touching and then
it was like if she is touching
boiling water it was obviously she never
experienced this
contact with so and the fact that they
if you see they look to the sky they
never seen before
then flies passing and they look to the
flies like
like what is this they never seen all of
this
they they they all live in cage so
that's why in a way you only can film it
in such unique situation and we knew
we cannot repeat it we knew we can only
have
we found this beautiful people in uk
who who are buying from their
from this lottery house they're buying
chickens and gives them second life
so they and we knew that sometimes a
couple of times in
in in years doing this
so we came we knew the date and we knew
we have
we will not have second chance we knew
that tomorrow reaction of chicken will
be different
so what we did it came couple of days
before
we test all positions of camera all
lenses all of our movement
we change how we can where is glide
where is clouds
how what will what we will do if they
run what we will do if they will not
do anything so we we imagine no
situation
and then in the far in fact all of this
is just what happened nothing more we
didn't feel mean even more
this is in a way i always believe the
best film is
when you film something unrepeatable as
their reaction to the world they never
seen before
and you found the right way to do it
then
connection of subject or situation you
film
and the way you from becoming
unrepeatable something unique
and probably iconic yes when i first saw
the chickens i was just completely
i mean there was like this kind of sense
of suspense and suspension at the same
time it's like a hitchcock
it's like a hitchcock movie when when
you i remember the
the clip where you you are following
them as they walk through the woods it's
like they're just
discovering the world and this
realization that they've never used
their legs they've never
found their wings they don't even know
that they have wings in
and to actually see that unfurl in front
of you
and and also know it not because
anyone's telling you it but because you
can actually
see it if you're paying attention you
can actually
see it and that to me is like it's it's
also a different way
of of treating the viewer
that the viewer you're trusting the
viewer to actually use their eyes and
and when and feelings and see something
i just wanted to add to that that
when we were in the in the field trying
to prepare for this shoot i think most
of us in the crew was sort of
a little bit you know we were not sure
that
all of these sort of ideas that victor
had or the
sort of almost predictions that he had
what was going to happen
was going to happen and it happened so
many times that we were
preparing preparing for a shoot
preparing for something extremely
particular like for the chickens
that they would look to the sky they
wouldn't know where they were they
wouldn't know how to
handle the situation of freedom and
when you're there with the camera and it
actually happens and you are
feeling the adrenaline of seeing that in
front of your eyes
what we actually prepared for for such a
long time actually happens
then you then you feel really privileged
working
with the documentary and also with such
a
uh let's say an ambitious filmmaker that
is actually
trying to live within these sort of
predictions of what's going to happen
and um this was many many special
moments like that during the shoot that
we
we thought something's going to happen
or we were hoping something's going to
happen and it actually happened
and it was very very beautiful you've
created such a masterful
and intimate and profoundly moving film
um i think breaking quite a lot of
ground in the documentary field
for which i'm eternally grateful and so
i thank you
both for being on this
q a with us here today and i hope
viewers will get a chance to see this
amazing film thank you